mais d'abord donc les répercussions du
conflit russo ukrainien sur le porte
monnaie des français avec un effet les
la russie touchée au portefeuille la
première batterie de mesures annoncées
hier par les européens et les etats-unis
vise à couper moscou des financements
occidentaux impossible pour le pays de
lever des fonds sur ces marchés par
ailleurs deux banques publiques russes
la tirelire du kremlin est celle qui
finance le secteur de la défense ne
peuvent plus effectuer de transactions
avec les états unis et l'europe et leurs
actifs sont gelés
de telles sanctions font craindre des
mesures de rétorsion forte mais le
ministre de l'économie se veut rassurant
l'économie française est peu exposé à la
russie la france exporte au moins de
sept milliards d'euros par an vers la
russie c'est à peine plus d'un pour cent
des exportations françaises et nous
apportons moins de 10 milliards d'euros
par an de russie
c'est moins de 2% des importations
françaises dont vous voyez que ce sont
des chiffres qui sont très réussis si en
termes de commerce l'économie ne devrait
pas trop souffrir le porte monnaie des
français pourrait lui bien être touché
la russie à la force des états faibles
c'est-à-dire des états qui nous menace
et qu'ils vont pouvoir de nuisance les
véritables pouvoirs de la russie devrait
dire poutine sur les poires de nuisance
nuisances militaire et nuisances
énergétique et c'est bien là le problème
l'allemagne vient de suspendre
l'autorisation du gazoduc nord stream 2
qui devait approvisionner les européens
en gaz russe alors que les prix de
l'énergie ont déjà explosé avec
l'augmentation de la demande mondiale le
coût va encore s'accroître la force
offrir à cette crise de l'énergie gaz et
électricité vont tout à fait
probablement voir leur prix augmenter et
il en sera probablement de même aussi en
ce qui concerne le pétrole et donc les
carburants le gouvernement avait déjà
prévu un blocage des tarifs du gaz pour
les particuliers en octobre de quoi
éviter une explosion du coût pour les
consommateurs
bruno le maire l'a sur la mesure sera
maintenue
quel impact pour notre économie c'est
donc le thème de notre débat avec sylvie
matelly bonsoir
économiste directrice adjointe de l'iris
gérard françois dumont bonsoir
professeur à la sorbonne auteur de
géopolitique de l'europe c'est aux
presses universitaires de france olivier
doran bonsoir sport cet avocat
spécialiste des sanctions économiques au
cabinet ashurst j'accueille également
mathieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique bonsoir mathieu sylvie matelly
c'est la question globale du débat pour
commencer ses sanctions économiques
contre la russie quelle conséquence
directe la si on essaye de parler aux
français qui nous regardent de l'heure
de leur porte-monnaie quelles
conséquences dirait que ça peut avoir
alors en tant que tel les sanctions qui
ont été prononcées comme ça a été très
bien dit mort notre ministre de
l'économie devrait avoir assez peu
d'impact puisque ont effectivement on
est très peu dépendant du commerce avec
la russie de manière plus indirecte et
c'est ce que philippe chalmin disait
dans votre reportage c'est qu'on peut
imaginer que les tensions géopolitiques
et puis le fait que l'europe se prive
des approvisionnements de gaz russe via
leur stream 2 puisse à un moment donné
ou un autre avoir un impact sur le prix
du gaz via la dépendance au gaz russe et
sur le prix le prix du baril de pétrole
qui est extrêmement sensible aux
tensions géopolitiques dans un contexte
toutefois où la croissance économique
mondiale ralentit et où finalement les
tensions sur les prix qui est
essentiellement expliqué par une
accélération de la croissance économique
depuis début 2000 21 vont baisser louer
c'est assez technique et a tout plein de
facteurs qui entrent en ligne de compte
mais ça reste assez incertain il ya un
autre élément qui va rentrer également
en ligne de compte et qui sera très
important c'est les rétorsions que va
prononcer vladimir poutine association a
néanmoins fait ce qui ne manquera pas de
faire il l'avait fait en tout cas en
2014 et en 2014 rappelez vous il avait
prononcé un embargo sur les importations
de produits agricoles européens et là
c'est les agriculteurs et toute la
filière agroalimentaire qui rend france
avait subi le contrecoup de ces
rétorsion donc pour l'instant il ya des
tas de deux vecteurs de transmission en
fait à l'économie française mais il faut
attendre de voir les évolutions d'autres
facteurs pour avoir vraiment l'impact
économique oui et puis surtout que les
premières sanctions annoncées même si
elles sont importantes même s'il ya
l'union européenne si les états unis
même s'il ya beaucoup d'autres pays le
canada l'australie enfin voilà une
rafale de sanctions compte et qui ont
été annoncées java françois du monde
pour l'instant est ce que vous diriez
mais on a bien compris que il ya encore
on peut encore pousser le curseur est ce
que vous diriez pour l'instant c'est
encore plus symbolique que réelle ces
sanctions telles qu'elles sont réels
mais elles sont quand même assez assez
faible c'est vrai qu'on risque d'avoir
une augmentation du prix de l'énergie
parce que si à la place du gaz russe
l'europe achète du gaz qui vient par des
métalliers le qatar ou bien du gaz de
schiste des états unis je pense quand
même que le coût de transport va être un
petit peu plus cher sans parler
effectivement des coûts de production il
est où ce avec le coût de production des
gaz de schiste sont quand même assez
élevé et en matière d'exportations et
bien on en sera inévitablement affaibli
néanmoins si on regarde un peu
l'histoire des sanctions et les effets
géopolitique des sanctions elles sont
quand même dans l'histoire assez limité
un mois je voudrais rappeler un exemple
est souvent oublié que celui de
l'afrique du sud est quand même un pays
qui a subi le plus de sanctions
économiques en raison de la situation
d'apartheid d'abord en réalité c'est
obligé l'afrique du sud a diversifié son
économie et à avoir une économie plus
productive pour des biens de première
nécessité et pour des biens d'équipement
pour les ménages se souvient aussi de la
russie ailleurs il sait les premières
filles exemples que vous citez moi je
connais des gens qui sont très pro russe
et qui sera fonds pour les sanctions
parce qu'ils disent enfin l'économie
russe qui était trop centrée sur des
matières premières va pouvoir se
diversifier ça va l'obliger à le faire
et donc ça va être un avantage
économique pour elle effectivement dans
l'histoire de l'afrique du sud fait la
décision de l'apartheid ce ne sont pas
les sanctions ce sont des décisions
internes à l'afrique du sud pour
rappeler d'ailleurs qu'on n'oublie que
ça a été un processus assez long en
tirant on parle toujours de la date
évidemment de 1994 en réalité on a tout
tout tout un ensemble de décisions sur
une dizaine d'années qui met en oeuvre
la suppression progressive de la part
des oliviers d'orgon justement nous on
est dans un processus on l'a bien
compris avec ces sanctions mais
est-ce que ça s'applique rapidement
j'essaye de comprendre ce à quoi comme
enjeu j'imagine vous conseillez à le
patron d'une entreprise française qu'est
les intérêts en russie
est-ce que c'est à très court terme et
en quelques semaines combien de temps sa
mère à agir finalement alors il ya une
différence d'approché assez fondamentale
entre les américains les européens et
les européens en tout cas en 2014 ont
d'une part essayé de privilégier
certains contrats existants et donc
n'ont fait appliquer les sanctions que
pour l'avenir et donc pas de manière
rétroactive aux états unis par contre on
est dans une réaction relativement
immédiate ceci dit pour les sanctions
qui sont sur le point d'être adopté ce
soir par l'union européenne vu qu'elles
n'ont toujours pas été précisée même si
on a quand même des indications assez
forte ce soir on est sur une application
immédiate parce qu'on est sur des
mesures de gel des avoirs principalement
et des mesures de gel des avoirs elle
impose effectivement pour répondre à
votre question directement aux
entreprises qui peuvent avoir des liens
commerciaux avec
différentes sociétés russes qui sont
détenues par ces nouveaux ces nouvelles
personnes sanctionnées à prendre des
mesures immédiatement par contre ce qui
est assez intéressant et je rebondis
tout à fait sur ce que vous disiez la
russie se prépare en 2014 la russie
avait un peu pris de court ça fait huit
ans maintenant que ces sanctions
existent quasiment copro vu que les
toutes premières ont été adoptées en
mars 2014 la russie se prépare la russie
a rapatrié ces capitaux la russie a
imposé à ses banques de sortir ses
avoirs qui étaient détenus par des
banques étrangères les ramener dans le
temps dans le territoire russe ah oui
c'est tourner également vers la chine on
le verra de manière énergétique donc
d'une certaine manière les sanctions
même si elles sont d'application
immédiate même si elle impose un peu de
travail pour les entreprises y sont
actives en russie elles n'auront pas
forcément des faits immédiatement pour
répondre à votre question sur la
temporalité il ya deux éléments vous
avez abordé mais on y reviendra on y
voit un chapitre en chapitre agriculture
et puis elle est rapide de la chine
temis est vraiment très important de ne
pas ne pas l'oublier mathias juste une
question sur la tombe d'un granit et
quand est-ce que ça s'arrête là les
solutions 2014 par exemple ça c'est
intéressant et solidaire c'est aussi une
des faiblesses
détiennent toujours raison été arrêtées
elles sont brisées alors en fait il ya
une différence fondamentale entre les
états unis et l'union européenne y
européenne on décide à 28 en 2014 à 27
en 2022 à l'unanimité donc très
clairement on
la condition de satigny l'unanimité
c'est de se revoir régulièrement tous
les ans pour renouveler les sanctions
les américains adoptent et ensuite il
faut un acte soit un décret présidentiel
sur un acte du congrès en fonction de
savoir si ce sont des sanctions du
congrès ou de l'exécutif américain pour
annuler mais elles sont indéfinie les
européennes sont tous les ans et c'est
assez intéressant parce qu'on voit des
dissensions au sein des états membres on
l'avait vu en 2015 par exemple la grèce
avait mis dans la balance de la
négociation de sa dette commerciale le
vote favorable pour le renouvellement
des sanctions dès 2015 donc on voit à
quel point au sein de l'union on peut
jouer de ses de cette unanimité et de
cette règle du renouvellement annuel
alors on va continuer de parler de du
gaz 27 cet aspect particulier et je
propose à quentin à calmer nos jeunes
parce que ça a été l'une des questions
ça la crise ukrainienne elle a vraiment
été abordés bonsoir au sénat lors de la
question d'actualité au gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est la toute dernière
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement qui se tient tous les
mercredis au sc n'a effectivement
puisque à la suspension pour la trêve
avec l'élection présidentielle et on a
vu pas moins de trois questions sur ce
sujet de la crise en ukraine tout
d'abord avec les communistes très sévère
sur l'action de l'otan les socialistes
eux très inquiet pour les 200000
ukrainiens qui sont sur la zone de
contact en ukraine et donc les
centristes inquiets sur votre sujet 1
celui qui voit là vous occupe ce sera au
tour de ce plateau sur les risques de
pénurie de gaz quand on sait donc que
40% et ça a été rappelé au sénat des
importations du vieux continent viennent
de russie ces barbares accompli qui a pu
répondre cet après midi lors des
questions d'actualité puisqu'elle
dispose dans son portefeuille du volet
sur l'énergie et écouter la réponse à la
mise donc c'est cet aprem au sénat et
demain si la russie devait cesser ses
exportations ce qui n'est pas à l'ordre
du jour actuellement nous ne courrons
pas de risques d'approvisionnement en
matière énergétique qu'il s'agisse des
carburants ou du gaz en particulier nous
avons des stocks stratégiques de pétrole
importantes qui couvre près de 90 jours
auprès de trois mois de notre
consommation et qui nous permettent de
faire face à des perturbations
d'approvisionnement et la ministre
d'ajouter pour être très clair je cite
les français ne risque pas de manquer de
carburant eau de gaz une réponse qui n'a
que moyennement convaincu les sénateur
surtout que au delà des trois mois que
va-t-il se passer à écouter la réplique
donc après la réponse barbara compile
juste du sénateur centriste françois
bonneau la dépendance de l'europe au gaz
russe a augmenté en dix ans de 24 à 40 %
pour passer au gaz naturel liquéfié qui
pourrait être une solution ce sera
coûteux et ce sera long
donc il est urgent d'avoir une politique
énergétique qui diminue notre dépendance
au gaz russe voilà c'est sur cette
incertitude thomas que se sont séparés
les sénateurs et le gouvernement
prochaine séance des questions d'actu
après les élections législatives merci
contester cet aprem pardon après cet
après midi angel jeu s'est passé par les
deux jeunes ça aussi c'est bon merci
le compte-rendu allez on redevient
sérieux avec peut-être des chiffres
assez précis sur les importations de gaz
en france est intéressant parce que le
gaz qu'on importe il vient
prioritairement de norvège à 36% de
russie nous y voilà 17% ensuite c'est
l'algérie et les pays bas et ça nous
rend évidemment l'a déjà dit sur ce
plateau moins dépendants par exemple que
l'allemagne sylvie matelly mais je
reviens à ce que disait le sénateur
centriste françois bonneau au delà de
trois mois en fait la question il ya la
question des sanctions est la question
du conflit évidemment si le conflit
dégénère là on n'est plus dans la même
dans la même mécanique sur la hausse des
prix on est d'autant plus dans la même
mécanique qu'il y aura probablement de
nouvelles sanctions qu'elles seront
imposées et donc de nouvelles rétorsion
de la part de vladimir poutine et de la
russie très clairement je pense que ce
sur quoi paris aujourd'hui le
gouvernement c'est le fait que dans
trois mois ce sera l'été et qu'on était
en consomment beaucoup moins de gaz donc
les tensions sur les marchés vont se
réduire et même si les facteurs
géopolitiques et le conflit ukrainien
attentes a poussé les prix du gaz à la
hausse ou à réduire nos
approvisionnements depuis la russie au
fond ce sera plus facile dans un an dans
une période estivale où on consomme
moins de gaz d'aller chercher des
alternatives qu en plein hiver quand il
fait très froid donc je crois que on est
on est sur cette logique là la question
qu'il faut se poser c'est est après
l'hiver tony se passe quoi très
clairement c'est vrai que
s'approvisionner
en gaz liquéfié basse pour l'instant
c'est pas à qui on n'est pas sûr de
pouvoir importer les quantités et on
reste très dépendante de la russie il ya
aussi une autre question qui va se poser
avec le gaz à l'arrivée de l'automne et
de l'hiver c'est que faut bien se
rappeler la fin de la tarification du
prix de l'électricité qui est en grande
partie dépendante des prix du gaz en
europe puisque on a un tarif unique du
bia de l'électricité en europe et là
aussi au delà du pétrole et du gaz s'est
peut-être l'électricité et le prix de
l'électricité qui va qui va flamber
pour ceux qui n'ont pas la chance d'être
encore sous des contrats avec des prix
régulés alors je parlais de l'allemagne
le chancelier allemand olaf scholz a
annoncé la suspension de l'autorisation
sur le gazoduc nord stream 2 qui doit
relier l'allemagne à la russie mais
enfin pour l'instant gérard françois
dumont on n'a pas coupé le
savoure toujours le nord stream alors
qu'on appelle maintenant quelques ça
existe toujours et de toute façon
la russie n'a aucun intérêt a cessé de
livrer du gaz à l'europe parce que ça
représente pour elle quand même des
ressources qui sont considérables et
même si elle se dit bien maintenant je
vais en livrer davantage à la chine est
moins à l'europe je pense que le gaz à
la chine il lui coûtera sans doute lui
rapportera parlant moins que la vente du
gaz en europe en plus le transport du
gaz en europe et notamment en allemagne
ne coûte pas très cher tian nord stream
à ça passe par la mer baltique
donc ya pas de royalty à payer à des
pays de passage et donc c'est nord
stream 2 vous rappeler que l'une des
raisons de la construction de north
reynders s'était aussi d'éviter
justement le passage par le sud qui
coûtait beaucoup plus cher et qui posait
des problèmes géopolitiques avec
notamment un certain nombre je dirais de
chefs d'entreprise ukrainien pour parler
gentiment qui avait tendance à
s'approprier le gaz au passage parce
qu'il faut rappeler que la russie
vendent à l'ukraine le gaz beaucoup
moins cher qu elle le vend au pays de
l'union européenne donc il avait trouvé
une astuce extraordinaire en ukraine il
prenait du gaz au passage au prix vendus
aux îles nous on est avec la revente et
au prix fort et à l'union européenne de
scintillement moscou a découvert ça ils
n'ont pas énormément apprécié la méthode
enfin et c'est l'une des récentes on le
veuille ou non en détention vous
rappeler que la russie a même menacé à
certaines périodes il a même fait je
crois quelques jours un moment de
supprimer le gaz à l'ukraine pour
qu'elle arrête cette espèce de
spéculations assez malhonnête que les
ukrainiens faisait à l'époque donc la
russie sur les c'est toujours le
problème des relations entre un
fournisseur et un client un client
dépens de son fournisseur mais un
fournisseur dépend de son client donc a
priori n'ont pas intérêt à se séparer a
divorcé totalement
comparatif entre l'union européenne et
la france dans ses relations économiques
avec la russie les liens entre la russie
et l'union européenne
l'union est le premier partenaire est le
premier investisseur de la russie ça
c'est intéressant si on zoome ensuite
alors donc on devrait pouvoir voir cette
voie là cette première infographie
ensuite si on zoome sur la france et je
reprends ce que disait le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire dans le sujet
tout à l'heure effectivement les
exportations vers la russie c'est 7
milliards d'euros 1 % moins de 1% des
exportations et c'est moins de 2% des
importations avec un peu moins de 10
milliards d'euros disait bruno le maire
olivier d'orgon je vois ces chiffres
j'entends ministre mais dans une
économique qe2 qui est quand même très
mondialisé globalisé même si on est
moins dépendant que d'autres de la
russie est ce que quand on a des groupes
français je pense par exemple à total
mais on a beaucoup d'autres qui sont
mondialisés est-ce qu'on peut échapper à
l'impact de sanctions économiques voyez
ce que je veux dire ça pose une bonne
question pose une réflexion qui est
également celle de l'harmonisation des
sanctions ce qu'on voit depuis cinq six
semaines maintenant depuis une escalade
des tensions de manière beaucoup plus
évidente en ukraine c'est des
discussions actives entre le royaume uni
l'union européenne les états unis et
d'autres d'autres pays sur des sanctions
harmoniser justement est un fonds unique
voilà pour pour aussi en fait éviter de
mettre des entreprises des
multinationales comme vous le dit très
justement dans des situations elle se
retrouve en fait soumises à des règles
au contraire pour reprendre votre votre
question sur sur sur la réaction des
groupes français un groupe français qui
est actif aux états unis au royaume uni
en russie de toute manière devra suivre
l'ensemble des sanctions qui sont édités
d'où l'importance de les annoncer en
même temps et qu'elles soient le mieux
coordonnée possible c'est ce que
l'europe et les états unis avaient déjà
fait en 2014 après pour répondre
peut-être plus directement à votre
question sur le l'impact pour les
entreprises les entreprises françaises
qui sont les multinationales oui les
impacts sont importants parce que les
activités même si effectivement en
termes d'importation d'exportation sont
des chiffres qui sont relativement
faibles et des investissements
considérables qui ont été faits par
certains acteurs notamment au secteur
énergétique en france en russie qui ont
d'ailleurs été pour certains un peu mis
en cause par la première vague de
sanctions 2014 on pense notamment à tous
de l'exploration en arctique au
développement du gaz et du pétrole de
schiste en russie dans les régions
vraiment au nord de la russie et ce sont
effectivement des dizaines de milliards
d'euros qui ont été investi par des
entreprises françaises en partenariat
avec ron nief gazprom neft avec d'autres
acteurs énergétiques en russie et qui
eux sont paul pour le coup
potentiellement menacées ou en tout cas
qui sont impactés et par les sanctions
européennes et par les sanctions
américaines et c'était je conclurai sur
sa l'objet des dissensions sur north
stream 2 avec des investissements
allemands qui étaient très importants et
les américains qui voulaient imposer des
sanctions tout secondaire un contre
north stream pour essayer de forcer la
main de l'allemagne avec une résistance
assez forte dans gala merkel sur la
fente sont de son quinquennat pour pour
se poser à ces mesures une parenthèse
dans ce débat sur le la diplomatie peut
encore faire
mathieu notamment sur le rôle des
mamelles macron il ay là il ya eu un
tweet juste après l'annnonce de l'animé
routine de reconnaître les régions
séparatistes du dombass bon voilà toute
assez classique réaction officielle
condamnant appelant à des sanctions
européennes mais à part ça il est
silencieux sur le dossier ukrainien
emmanuel macron
on peut parler d'un camouflet qui a été
infligée par ses routines donc bien
inspiré a besoin c'est vrai que il a
découvert que la eva double discours
chef des émirs martin ou en tout cas
qu'il en avait été victime qui devait
peut-être pris quelque chose pour pour
trop beau à savoir la tenue de ce
potentiel sommet il devait se tenir
d'ailleurs demain jeudi là tous les
rendez-vous ont été ont été annulés la
la la communication c'est pas de vagues
et surtout ça ça ne touchera pas c'est
ce que dit bruno le maire avec une forme
d'oubli ou d'angle mort qui est que vous
pouvez voir des marchés qui dévisse vous
pouvez avoir un impact psychologique sur
l'économie les marchés qui dévisse donc
des entreprises derrière qui sont pas
forcément connecter aux marchés
financiers mais qui disent pour là c'est
pas le moment d'investir ce qu'il va y
avoir une crise est ce que jean bauchet
ce que j'embauche pas on a déjà vu des
chocs géopolitiques avoir des
traductions concrètes dans un cône une
époque où le moindre événement au
proche-orient suffisait déjà à faire
bouger pétrole et donc du coup entraîné
choses comme ça on n'y est pas mais mais
ça c'est l'angle mort de deux de
l'analyse à bonnot maire gérard france
on aime ça effectivement c'est important
parce que quand on parle des
investissements par exemple de total en
russie dans ses investissements il ya
tout l'aspect savoir faire c'est à dire
en fait le fait que total a
effectivement des ingénieurs qui sont
extrêmement compétents et dont la russie
a besoin pour pouvoir mieux exploiter
ses réserves
d'hydrocarbures donc à supposer que le
conflit s'envenime que la frontière soit
fermée qui est plus la possibilité de
ces échanges de savoir faire ça veut
dire que effectivement les risques
économiques pour nous très important
mais je reviens sur le jeu de la
diplomatie est ce que il n'y a pas
d'autres pays que la france mieux placé
pour jouer les médiateurs dans ce qu'on
fait on peut penser à la finlande à
l'autriche l'un des pays qui ont
l'habitude de parler avec les russes
quoi mais le problème c'est que je pense
qu'il faut il faut revenir à l'essentiel
c'est à dire quelle est la nature de ce
conflit non en fait que ce conflit il me
paraît assez simple c'est à dire qu'on
avait la russie et l'ukraine qui était
marié il était marié avec un régime de
communauté universelle enfin duré
jusqu'en 1990 bon et bien sûr depuis
1990 mais on est dans un processus de
divorce avec des hauts et des bas mais
le problème c'est qu'il ya quand même
des éléments par de partage et ils ne
savent pas comment les partager parce
qu'en gros la russie dit bien vous voyez
regarder les frontière occidentale de
l'ukraine c'est grâce à moi que vous les
avez et notamment parce que j'ai gagné
la guerre comme entre hitler et donc
j'ai réussi à gagner pour vous des
territoires qui auparavant dépendez ou
de l' empire austro-hongrois avant la
première guerre mondiale où ou de la
pologne à un autre moment quant aux
frontières orientales de l'ukraine la
russie a toujours dit mais rappelez-vous
ce sont des terres russes qu'on vous a
quand vous a donné pour agrandir votre
territoire et concernant la crimée il
faut rappeler que la crimée avant 1939
est une république une des républiques
de l'urss donc vous êtes en train de
dire que voilà on patine année un an
mais c'est aux frais territoire non mais
c'est très compliqué la situation
c'était une république de l'urss qui
était qui a quitté autant autonome que
les autres dans la mesure on peut parler
d'autonomie au sein du rsa cris et le
problème c'est qu'elle a été occupé
pendant quatre ans par l'armée
hitlérienne et donc staline en 1945 pour
effectivement
expliqué aux ukrainiens autres hawke aux
habitants crient mais qu'il n'était pas
content parce qu'ils avaient un peu
gentil avec les allemands à supprimer
totalement le statut de république de
l'urss à la crimée et on en a fait 1,5
au blast et puis donc un simple cadre
administrative et puis comme vous le
savez en 1954 khrouchtchev a décidé de
réunir cette glace donc si vous comprend
un pardon parce que l'histoire c'est
passionnant
mais dont vous dites quoi un peu tort
partager c'est ça puisqu'on parle de
1000 force si on reprend toute
l'histoire oui nous nous un peu on a un
peu les juges aux affaires familiales
dans cette affaire si je puis dire en
quelque sorte mais si on regarde la
situation la gamme est désormais
beaucoup plus complexe que d'un côté il
ya les bons et de l'autre côté il ya les
mauvais moi j'adore quand on a de la
complexité c'est d'abord le poids de la
nuance dans ce dans cette émission est
alors comme promis on va parler de la
chine maintenant parce que si lui matt
ellis est vraiment un très important je
reviens aux sanctions qu'on soit bien
d'accord s'il ya un axe moscou pékin qui
secret ça ça dévitalise un petit peu
l'effet des sanctions est ce qu'on peut
dire ça alors très clairement et c'est
une partie de l'adaptation aux sanctions
conques ont organisé les russes après
2014 les exportations aujourd'hui et la
vente de gaz à la chine s'est
intensifiée ces dernières années parce
que depuis 2014 les russes ont mis en
service un an et vont construire un
gazoduc qui permet d'approvisionner la
chine en gaz alors c'est moins
intéressante les relations avec la avec
l'europe ça a été dit mais malgré tout
c'est un nouveau débouché et c'est une
partie de ceux qui expliquaient à
l'automne l'augmentation du prix du gaz
russe c'est qu'ils avaient une
concurrence qui était qui était fait et
qui permettait à la russie de se
positionner soit à l'est soit l'ouest
donc ça c'est un premier élément c'est
un élément très important on a
aujourd'hui du mal à décrypter quelle va
être l'attitude de la chine parce que
dans les sanctions il ya plusieurs
éléments il ya l'impact l'efficacité des
sanctions sur le pays que vous
sanctionnez bon on l'a tous dit elle
risque d'être assez limité d'abord parce
que les sanctions restent assez limités
et ensuite parce que là la russie s'est
habituée aux sanctions depuis depuis
huit ans à présent donc ça c'est un
premier élément le deuxième élément
c'est l'impact que vont avoir les
sanctions sur nous les fonctionnaires et
ça on a vu avec les sanctions de 2014
que pour certains secteurs d'activité on
a parlé de l'agriculture on a parlé de
l'énergie et du secteur l'énergie on
aurait pu parler aussi du secteur du
luxe puisque s'étonne le marché russe
est l'un des débouchés mais le troisième
élément c'est la capacité que peut avoir
un pays à sanctionner à contourner les
sanctions est en fait dans les sanctions
de 2014 la chine a offert cette
possibilité à la russie parce qu'il y
avait un rapprochement qui était qui
étaient en cours et qui n'a fait que
s'intensifier et qui a finalement jeté
les russes dans les bras de la chine ça
souvent été des gi et décrypter la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
est-ce que ça va s'amplifier est ce que
les chinois vont finalement
fermé les yeux sur ce que sont en train
de faire les russes
rien n'est moins sûr on les entend très
peu les chinois pour une bonne et simple
raison c'est qu'ils ont des intérêts
économiques avec le cren ils ont aussi
des intérêts économiques avec l'union
européenne
du tout envie de se fâcher plus que
nécessaire avec les états unis donald
trump est en partie on se rend compte
que joe biden a montré un petit peu
qu'il qu'il était sur la même ligne que
tron dans sa relation à la chine mais
dans la vraie vie il ya une
intensification des négociations
économiques et commerciales avec une
entente très forte entre janet yellen et
son homologue chinois ou
chargé des questions environnementales
aux états unis vous nous posez une colle
mais qui a été qui a été candidat à une
époque à l'élection présidentielle est
une question climatique sur les
questions elle se laisse al gore pas du
tout non non pas du tout pas du tout
honneur c'est
bref c'est vrai il ya eu un accord il ya
eu une déclaration commune à l'issue de
glasgow et de la coop là comme 26 entre
la chine et les états unis sur les
questions climat donc mine de rien il ya
quand même un rapprochement qui s'est
opéré sur certains dossiers accord dans
le dossier économique et climatique
entre les états unis et la chine je
doute que les chinois veuille remettre
100 go 10 ans sur cette question de la
chine là aussi si on rentre la mécanique
des sanctions pour bien comprendre ce
qui se passe ailleurs on peut on peut
quoi on peut on pourrait interdire ça
pourrait interdire à des entreprises
chinoises de continuer de faire du
business avec les états unis
si si elle est trop la chine c'est très
binaire ce que je dis est sûrement mais
j'essaie de comprendre non en fait
effectivement la grèce pourrait que je
l'action de contournement moi me paraît
pas forcément le mot le plus juste parce
que l'adaptation en l'occurrence les
sanctions européennes s'appliqueront
européen schématiquement les sanctions
américaines s'applique de manière plus
extraterritoriale je pense qu'on en a
tous l'entrée longuement débattu
les sanctions européennes et américaines
ne s'applique pas en chine donc je suis
une entreprise chinoise je peux très
bien continuer de commercer librement et
par ailleurs les chinois se sont montrés
très féroce quand il assagi cantine
c'est ça il a été la question par le
passé de vouloir sanctionner des
entreprises chinoises au motif qu'elles
contrevenaient aux sanctions américaines
on pense au dossier wide notamment et on
pense aux contres mesures que la chine a
prise depuis 2020 qui ont été assez peu
commentée ici mais qui permettra au
gouvernement chinois de sanctionner des
entreprises étrangères qui forcerait des
entreprises chinoises à se soumettre à
leur régime de sanctions donc tout ça
pour dire qu'effectivement
je parle d'adaptation plus que de
contournement est peut-être pour
rebondir au-delà du secteur énergétique
et les acteurs financiers le secteur
financier on a aussi longtemps parlé ces
dernières semaines de swift et d'une
éventuelle des connexions alors est-ce
qu'on peut rappeler précisément ce
qu'est swift c'est en une organisation
internationale qui est venu sécurisé
dans les années soixante dix pour dire
les choses simplement les communications
entre banques pour apporter de la
sécurité avec des formats de messages
harmonisée qui permettent à des
établissements bancaires de savoir
qu'elles ont toutes les informations
nécessaires pour de faire des opérations
plus ou moins complexes de transfert de
crédits documentaires ou quatre
les
99% des banques mondiales souscrivent à
swift et elles ont accès à ses capacités
et il a été dès 2014 question parce
qu'on avait le président iranien en 2012
2 déconnectez certaines banques russes
proche de poutine de swift pour leur
empêcher de communiquer de manière
sécurisée avec les banques américaines
et les banques européennes ce café
m'admirent poutine dès décembre 2014 et
il a dit je vais créer un réseau
concurrent à swift qui s'appelle spf est
ce qui est un réseau qui a été mise en
oeuvre à partir de 2017 qui a
aujourd'hui la quasi totalité des
banques russes et des compagnies
d'assurances russe souscrivent à ce à ce
système est fait intéressant il ya douze
banques étrangères qui sont ceux qui
souscrivent à ce canal alternatif est la
principale c'est la banque centrale de
chine donc on pourrait se dire qu
éventuellement adaptation à nouveau dans
l'hypothèse de 2,2 sanctions sur sa faim
de déconnexion de swift on bascule sur
autre chose et tout dernier point sur le
secteur financier on voit l'union
européenne d'ailleurs annoncé des
restrictions aux accès aux marchés de
capitaux renforcées pour les banques
russes on peut se demander dans quelle
mesure des capitaux chinois ne voient
pas venir également abondé les réserves
des banques russes se si elle venait à
manquer alors je reviens au l'un des
thèmes on a fait la chine et on n'a pas
encore détaillé la question de
l'agriculture en jeu vraiment important
des sanctions qui inquiète la présidente
de la fnsea on écoute christiane lambert
les sanctions financières contre la
russie créer un risque énorme de mesures
de rétorsion contre les produits de
l'union européenne au premier rang
desquels encore les produits agricoles
il y a aussi des incidences sur les
marchés que nous craignons l'ukraine les
deux hommes qui ont été envahies la
laine et à l'est de l'ukraine représente
une part importante de la production de
blé ukrainien tous pour cent des
exportations mondiales de blé vient
d'ukraine 12 % et elles vont
essentiellement vers l'egypte et
l'indonésie donc il ya un risque de
moins de produits de livraison vers ces
zones là donc de pénurie alimentaire
dans des régions ça peut représenter une
instabilité politique également on se
souvient des émeutes de la faim qui est
des soulèvements en afrique du nord donc
cette déstabilisation de la géopolitique
du blé elle est très préoccupant
effectivement le poids de la russie dans
le marché du blé ces 11 % de la
production mondiale entre 18 et 20% des
exportations mondiales sont source
chambre d'agriculture de de france et
l'ukraine c'est aussi important
l'ukraine s'est on parle souvent de
grenier à blé de l'europe est ce que
gérard françois dumont ou dirais que
c'est l'un des enjeux de ce conflit
est-ce que je hais ce qu'une petite
lorgne blé ukrainien
évidemment poutine dans sa situation
actuelle il considère qu'il faut qu'ils
affaiblissent l'ukraine ça c'est sûr
dans la mesure où il veut a fait bien
l'ukraine il a intérêt effectivement vu
de son point de vue de s'emparer de
partie de l'ukraine qui sont
économiquement plus dynamique et et
qu'on le veuille ou non le bassin du don
même si c'est pas tout le bassin du dont
il s'empare
et bien c'est quand même une partie de
l'ukraine qui a toujours eu un niveau
économique relativement intéressant et
donc qu'on ne peut pas dire qui prend en
ukraine et les territoires les moins
intéressants économiquement donc ça
quand même de l'importance pour lui
est-ce que l'agriculture française est
effectivement en première ligne dans
dans le dans le risque économique dont
on parle depuis le début
très clairement et outre parce que il ya
l'agriculture française à des débouchés
importants en russie rappelez-vous toute
la polémique qui a eu cet été sur la
question du champagne on voit aussi un
que les russes sont très friands de
produits agricoles et agroalimentaires
français donc des rétorsions sur cette
impasse sur ce secteur là aurait un
impact très très fort ça c'est évident
et est d'autant plus que après les
sanctions de 2014 on s'est aperçu aussi
que la russie cc rétorsion sur sur les
produits agricoles et les importations
de produits agricoles avaient eu pour
effet de dynamiser en fait le secteur
agricole et agroalimentaire en russie
donc c'est un double effet en fait d'un
côté vous êtes pénalisé parce que vous
pouvez plus importer puis à la fin vous
retrouvez avec un nouveau concurrent
extrêmement efficace et qui plus est
dans un moment où l'augmentation des
prix de l'énergie a pesé sur toutes les
matières premières et qu'on a vu ces
derniers mois également une augmentation
des prix d'un certain nombre de produits
agricoles donc déjà des tensions sur cet
aspect là des difficultés pour les
agriculteurs donc on est vraiment dans
un contexte qui est très très compliqué
pour l'agriculture et sur le jeu revient
au porte monnaie des français sur le
prix
des produits liés au blé et les céréales
la baguette c'est
alors ça peut peser ça peut peser parce
que les prix sur les marchés mondiaux
augmentent là où ça va peut-être plus
impactés c'est que notre agriculture est
quand même un élément favorable de notre
balance commerciale en a pas tant que ça
si on subit moins les effets des
sanctions c'est aussi parce que on est
moins présent à l'export et qu'au fond
ma on est on est moins sensible une
dégradation des conditions commerciales
à l'étranger c'est pas le cas pour
l'agriculture c'est pas le cas pour
l'agriculture et du coup ça risque de
pénaliser à la fois les agriculteurs et
le consommateur français olivier d'orgon
des mesures de représailles de rétorsion
russe ça peut être produit par produit
on peut dire à vous parler du champagne
ça peut être par exemple plus de
champagne français alors ça peut être de
nature ça peut être effectivement par
secteurs d'activité agriculture produits
du luxe de luxe par exemple ça peut être
intéressant aussi de voir comment est ce
que la russie a aussi appris de son de
son grand frère chinois qui comme je
vous le disais depuis 2020 a également
mis en place des règlements de blocage
qui interdisent là aussi aux entreprises
russes de se conformer aux entreprises
françaises qui sont actives en aussi de
se conformer aux sanctions européennes
ou américaines donc ce qui peut être
intéressant c'est oui des secteurs
d'activité mais à mon avis une réponse
peut-être encore plus intelligente de la
part de la russie pour justement venir
sanctionner des entreprises présentes
sur le territoire on pense à ce moment
là aux fameuses joint-venture notamment
dans le secteur de l'énergie qui
viendraient parce qu'elles y sont
soumises appliquer le droit européen où
le droit américain et qui se verraient
sanctionnés par les russes pour
justement respecter la réglementation à
laquelle ils sont soumises et ce qui est
passionnant je vous écoute depuis tout à
l'heure en fait c'est votre spécialité
mais ça fait tellement longtemps qu'on
applique des sanctions économiques dans
différents conflits un peu partout dans
le monde que où on a on a hantée des
réponses quoi parle t on parle de
sanction puis la russie ça va vraiment
être un temps dans le sanctions même si
effectivement l'apartheid a été arrêté a
été la raison de l'imposition des plus
grandes sanctions dans l'histoire des
sanctions les sanctions c'est un peu un
instrument juridique ont objectivement
personnes auxquelles personne ne portait
vraiment attention parce que ça concerne
l'iran la corée du nord cuba pour les
américains en 2014 on s'est dit on a le
choix entre une intervention militaire
très populaire en plus à l'époque de la
débâcle américaine en irak et en
afghanistan ou le remettre au goût du
jour cet instrument donc les diplomates
qui ont construit ces sanctions en 2014
les ont d'ailleurs appelé sanctions
sectorielle sanctions intelligentes
cibler précisément et il faut se dire
que quand on a ce type de sanction on a
des contre-mesures et c'est pour ça que
la chine en 2020 adopté des mesures
intelligent pour venir en famille
mathieu il peut y avoir aussi un effet
de ricochet sur les sanctions faut
rappeler que la bnp par exemple avait
été condamné à payer une amende de 9
milliards aux états unis pour avoir
violé une loi fédérale américaine et les
écrêtés un embargo sur cuba sur le sofa
beaucoup de mal à beaucoup beaucoup
objet a ricoché belleville dans la tête
des gens c'est une banque française a dû
payer une amende évidemment les des
activités internationales et notamment
aux états unis parce qu'on l'a on
l'accusait d'avoir violé les embargos
qu'avait été décrétés par les états unis
c'est ce cas oui effectivement aussi
contribuer au nouvel essor de cet outil
mais la raison pour laquelle bnp a été
sanctionné en 2014 c'est parce qu'elle
avait effectivement des points de
rattachement parce qu'elles utilisaient
une dollars et notamment la doua
phosphorer dans les services d'une
angine des grands groupes internationaux
français aujourd'hui au point de vue des
sanctions il faut rappeler aussi toutes
les sanctions contre la russe dans
contre la syrie dans l'objectif était
clairement d'obliger bachar el-assad
d'abandonner le pouvoir et a priori il
est toujours au pouvoir alors c'est vrai
que son pays est extrêmement apories
mais ce qu'on voit c'est que les les dpi
par exemple du moyen-orient comme
l'arabie saoudite comme les émirats
arabes unis qui avaient aussi mis en
place des sanctions très forte contre le
régime de bachar el assad mais elles les
ont quasiment abandonnées elles ont
renoué leurs relations diplomatiques
avec lui et on voit que maintenant les
relations entre la jordan et la syrie
sont ragde remise en place et puis on a
un exemple d'actualité pardonnez moi
c'est le manille où là aussi le mali
vient de subir un certain nombre de
sanctions pour obliger sa junte a enfin
donné une date aux meubles pour que on
retrouve un régime civil au mali pour le
moment ça n'a pas fait bouger d'un pouce
le régime du vally donc là le géo
politiques l'emportent en impression sur
les effets des sanctions un dernier
chiffre et je reviens à la question de
l'agriculture sûr on en parle moins on
parle beaucoup de blé mais sur le marché
des engrais on a découvert ce chiffre en
préparant les missions la russie acteurs
majeurs de ce marché seize pour cent du
commerce mondial des engrais donc là
aussi on va terminer là dessus si me
mattei ce qui est intéressant c'est que
tout notre débat il s'inscrit aussi dans
ce qui est un enjeu qui est montée très
fort depuis deux ans avec la avec la
pandémie actions de la relocalisation de
la souveraineté économique sur des
drones des denrées majeur pour pour
l'équipe du pays donc ça ça renforce les
arguments là notamment dans le cadre de
cette campagne tout à fait et ce qui est
très intéressant dans ce débat sur les
sanctions les nouvelles sanctions qu on
imposerait la russie c'est que justement
se questionne sur l'impact que vont
avoir ses sanctions sur nous mêmes c'est
assez nouveau dans le débat s'était pas
posé la question comme ça en 2014 et au
fond ça nous en dit long sur le fait que
les sanctions elle nous coûte peut-être
plus cher qu'elle ne non d'efficacité
mais malgré tout est ce qu'on peut ne
rien faire et la grande difficulté avec
la russie et la grande nouveauté avec la
russie c'est que la plupart du temps
quand on parle des sanctions à
l'encontre de la birmanie etc au départ
il y avait d'abord des sanctions
multilatérales imposé par la nation unie
parfois complétées par les états unis et
de façon unilatérale voire l'union
européenne mais on était sur un concert
des nations pour imposer des sanctions
contre un régime dans le cas de la
russie c'est totalement impossible
puisqu'on nations unies tout le monde le
sait il son conseil de sécurité donc ils
vont mettre leur veto à ce qu'on leur
impose des sanctions donc on est obligé
d'y aller tout seul mais là vous rentrez
dans une sorte de jungle où au fond vous
savez vous devez imposer des sanctions
pour marquer le coup pour dire on peut
pas laisser faire mais vous vous
retrouvez coincé parce que ces sanctions
chacun fait ce qu'il veut
la russie peut imposer des rétorsions
puisqu'on n'est plus du tout dans un
cadre multilatéral
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat vous avez retrouvé
le nom de l'homme politique jeunes qui
rit john kerry voilà qui vous cherchez
une toutes les infos du merci beaucoup
j'ai à françois dumont géopolitique de
l'europe c'est aux presses
universitaires de france merci encore
une fois d'avoir participé à ce débat